matt yoshi have you seen it
yeah i've seen it uh three times
you saw it three times
yeah i watched it uh
once just like as a fan and then i
watched it more like as a comedian and
then i watched it just like just to like
catch all the other stuff uh like
attached to it because i'm a fan
of her first special i really really
like her first special um and i like her
joke writing uh yeah she's very short
i'm
very very sharp joke writer yes i think
yeah yeah very just solid joke writer so
yeah i i liked it
overall
very nice yeah i definitely enjoyed just
how personal it was that was definitely
something that stuck out to me
uh before we get into like the math of
it is just how personal it was and how
she went to those 100
dark places like talking about
her mental health and therapy and
you know panic attacks and being bipolar
and emotional eater and her mom dying
and like she tackles a lot of topics and
i think the big thing
and this is something uh i think during
our last live stream yoshi was like you
should go watch ali wong's new special
that one's crazy and it
and it opens with like just
body fluids on my face
like so she's doing and hey you do you
any comic out there you do what you find
funny i'm not saying what aly did is not
funny or wrong i'm just saying it was a
sex joke done in one way and then
taylor's able to do sex jokes in another
way that they're still sex jokes but
they're not as explicit and like just
graphic but they still get the point
across you know which
i just i just appreciate the finesse of
that joke writing style but you know it
was funny to watch allies and then this
one and see the contrast of like topics
and how they were executed
and with ali she was very descriptive
yeah yeah did you get through alleys
yeah no i didn't get through
yeah okay uh and that that told me i
told you i was like joel my bad i
thought you've seen an ali wong special
before which is why i suggested it and
if you've never seen an ali long special
this one is not the one to start
for sure
like
it is it is the wrong one to start with
like she's a you gotta you gotta cleanse
your palate with the first one like
which i think is baby cobra and then the
second one is i i like that one too and
then the third i mean i've liked all her
specials but yeah i think
i love the fact that taylor took this
special
it felt very very personal but also like
very introspective like there was just a
lot of like
not only are you talking about the
personal stuff but you're also like
challenging yourself so it's very like
self-deprecating while also getting into
your own
stuff
about like why you are the way that you
are in all honesty it felt like uh it
felt like a therapy session
to be honest with you yeah i kind of
took it
it was almost like we were in her
therapy session
of the things that she was struggling
with throughout the entire special and i
enjoyed that because to your point
you don't see that a lot there's not a
lot of like people putting that out
there
yeah for sure yeah and it reminded me
also of like
matt rife i don't know if y'all have
seen his special on youtube yet but like
he's like a super attractive dude
and he's talking about having anxiety
and depression and all of this uh so
it's interesting like seeing someone
like taylor
you see them as one way just based on
how they look but then the complexity
behind that is what i love about
comedians in general is that we're never
what we seem
and there's always there's always some
hidden emotional
something i mean i don't want to get
like too dramatic about it but it's just
fun to see like
taylor could easily be like oh dating is
hard aren't i cute and like same thing
with matt rife he could be like i look
like hercules like laugh at me but like
they use comedy as a way to get into
those dark places which is what we
always challenge and encourage comics to
do it's easier said than done but to see
it executed at a level like taylor
i think it really makes it like
attainable and gives a like a living
breathing example of like oh here's how
we can talk about these dark things in a
very like um
palatable way
yeah yeah for sure um i want to hear the
breakdown chris yeah yeah me too yeah we
we cut off chris there i just want to
get into like the overall you know just
her going there okay so she was on stage
for 59 minutes
and got 427 laps
and so she was getting seven laps a
minute uh which breaks it down to a
laugh every eight seconds
for 59 minutes you said
59 yep yeah whoo
yeah that's solid yeah very solid
yeah with with those
uh i just
it's like last week we talked about
earthquake
we can go there if you want joel
no no no i'm not going anywhere you know
what was interesting
i'm not going anywhere negative but what
was interesting
don't go there no no no what i was
saying was if we were to to
like put it into perspective with
earthquake special he would have gotten
668 laughs had it been 59 minutes
at that pace yeah at that point yeah and
like you said
last week legendary is seven to ten laps
per minute
for an hour
yeah but i'm just saying
even taylor special
doing that pace for an hour
is
no joke
that is
a high level that's a lot
yeah yeah high level high energy
and and like i said last week seven six
to seven laps a minute you're a legend
and yeah she was at that seven minute uh
seven laps a minute
every single time yeah easy
yeah
um one of my favorite things in
comparing it to the earthquake special
i thought um earthquake in his special
has a section about these damn kids
ain't the way that they used to be i
felt like he was talking about taylor
tomlinson uh i know this like like just
straight up like these are the kids that
aren't the same
like and i know he's talking about his
kids but like
everything that he talked about like
in that like kids are not that they're
sensitive but like i like a kid in the
room he's going to write a a suicide
note they can't take it like it was just
like so in watching that special than
watching this it's almost like it's a
generational thing it's almost like
taylor is the kid that earthquake was
talking about
nope and i was like yo
but this talk but and then you talk
about matt rife i feel like even comics
today it's hard to talk about stuff
that's not even mental health because so
many kids are going through it i don't
want to say kids i i've been through it
so like so many people are going through
it just as a topic of conversation so it
was just interesting to watch like
a legend talk about his kids and then
almost like someone who represents his
kids
but even generationally though it's like
i do feel like
taylor
and i think taylor's is she 30 yet i
don't know
mate late 20s
it's a younger generation that is
talking more about mental health and
whatnot and like earthquakes generation
is more of just like ah
suck it up
you know tough it out put some dirt on
it you know so it is interesting to see
all these different perspectives about
the same topic
but she goes there i mean talking about
being
bipolar talking about your mom dying
talking about being bipolar i mean
yeah it was a good it was a good um
example to comedians that
the a lot of comedians like to use the
stage as therapy uh
but she took this and
flipped it into something funny but you
could tell she worked it out before she
got on stage you didn't use the stage to
work it out that makes sense
yeah
that yeah that came up in my q a last
week
you can say whatever you want it's gotta
be funny
it's gotta be funny
so yes go up there confess your
your
life struggles but there's got to be a
punchline so despite taylor
saying all these things all these
different antidepressants and all these
different things she's going through
there were punch lines throughout it
every eight seconds there was a punch
line to reinforce the topic she's
talking about so yes it's aspirational
to do material like taylor is doing but
also have the context of understanding
joke writing and making sure you can
make funny jokes out of mundane things
and then use that skill set to build
upon oh hey by the way i'm bipolar and
by the way i get night terrors and by
the way this is you know me and my
mom and dad's relationship and stepmom
and
all these things you know it's yeah it's
one bite at a time but taylor's
on all cylinders with this one
stood out to me was the amount of like
comparisons that she did
so
with the night terror she was like i now
am i am now on medication
that's like and then she would add
and she did that a lot but it painted
the picture of like
you
this is how bad it is
but to put it into a funny perspective
here's
where i think it should go
and it was very smart it was a smart
special i really enjoyed it
it was very smart one of my favorite
things
sorry go ahead no you you got it let her
rip there
i'm gonna say one of my favorite things
that she did um
that i think is just unique
is i love it when a very super confident
comedian tells you hey we're about to
get into eight minutes of dead mom jokes
yeah but don't worry we're gonna be
great like and like just the level of
confidence to tell an audience this is
gonna be uncomfortable but i've already
been through this so this should
actually be okay for you guys i enjoyed
watching her like set that up and then
knock it down with jokes all the way
through like that was super enjoyable
just to set up the audience for that
like it was almost like a okie doke but
it was like honest yo we're going to
talk about this topic
for a little while
and you're going to let me talk about it
but i promise you it's going to be funny
i enjoy just that level of confidence so
yeah there were several there were
several times that she kind of stepped
on the laugh
um
but came back and it like doubled the
the laughter
volume that makes sense like like it was
a small punch they giggled but she went
right into it and then it just got a
like eruption
and
the other thing that that stood out to
me was that this was more like an arena
type versus earthquakes was more like a
club type
yeah
and so you could tell that the laughs
were coming
but she paused a little longer to get
the laughs to her whereas earthquakes
was just bang bang bang bang they were
just laughing the whole time
um
yeah that's something that you gain with
experience
waiting for the laughter but yeah i
noticed that right away i also noticed
how she uses her facial expressions a
lot to get the laugh
and to sell the joke uh and i got that
from uh smiles a lot
yeah from uh jerry jerry lewis
um
that that's what he did a lot
in his in his movies
what using his face you're saying
yeah yeah the the uh
bellhop i think was the name of the
movie the doorman uh-huh
he didn't talk for the first 45 minutes
it was all facial expressions oh wow
yeah and he sold the whole [__] movie
it's crazy
whoa
yeah yeah so she did do a good job of
yeah physicalizing what she's talking
about also and
i think smiling while talking about
tough topics
is kind of the the sugar that helps the
medicine go down
you know what i mean yeah yep
yeah she did a lot of um
what i call like
like fourth wall
breakage of just telling people what
like she broke the fourth wall a lot and
then went back into the joke structure
very like kind of like the
the mom thing about i'm about to tell a
whole bunch of mom jokes get ready kind
of thing she did that a couple of times
throughout the set and it felt like i
think for me it felt like she was also
bringing people into the world of like
comedy a little bit of just like hey
this is what's gonna happen and i'm
gonna show you what i'm about to do and
i enjoyed like watching that part
because she's never done that on any of
her specials she's been like super
professional no breakage like just
straight up jokes jokes jokes jokes and
to your point chris
when something didn't land or it didn't
land in the way that she wanted it
she actually
was affected by it and did something
about it so like
when the audience got like uncomfortable
she like recognized it rather than like
because in a stadium like that i mean in
a large setting like that you could just
keep going with your jokes but she like
stopped and acknowledged oh yeah this is
uncomfortable for you guys but i'm about
to take you on this ride either way so i
like that
yeah there was something that she said
too that that stood out she said i don't
ever use the ther i don't ever use the
stage for therapy and then she looked at
the crowd and said unless i'm being paid
for it yeah and that's it
it made me laugh because it was such a
real uh statement that she was doing
that but i like that part where she
talked about her mom dying
and then like like said i'm gonna do six
minutes of dead mom jokes be ready
and so she did the six minutes
and then kind of like went into a new
joke and then brought her mom up again
and said told you i'd bring her back up
and it was like
breaking that fourth wall down again it
was funny
yeah she did several callbacks as well i
mean it was clearly a well thought out
yeah like arc of a of a special you know
i mean oh yeah really she was on top of
her game there
yeah on also
you're good
i was gonna say i love
every angle that she touched on like
my relationship my father my mother
my sex life like she touched on a lot of
personal stuff my breakups why my breaks
up have been terrible so like
you know as someone who's in therapy it
felt like a therapy session like i was
just like yo this is kind of the stuff
that like oh do you see a pattern here
and then you're like oh okay i guess
it's just me and then like but she's
joking about all these things so as a
person in therapy i found it to be very
like
like uh
what's the word
um
accommodating i was like oh
that is how therapy is like it was just
very much like a therapy session in
terms of like all the breakdowns that
she did with her own stories around it
the detective
using the red yarn the red yarn
yeah great
great way to break down therapy and very
visual also yep very visual
yeah
yeah i think my big
my big takeaway is just how personal it
is you know i always try to keep pushing
to get more personal and
but it's hard and it's scary you know so
to see someone like talking about being
an emotional eater and being bipolar and
your mom dying it really got
it's it's inspiring to keep moving in
that direction you know she's doing at a
very high level
and uh it's just
it's scary to go there but she does it
so effortlessly
seemingly
that uh it makes it feel more attainable
which which was like the biggest
inspiring thing i took away from it
yeah
so
as a as a veteran with ptsd
i have yet to touch on my military
service
in comedy like that like
i can talk about my kids my wife the
military stuff i did 14 years in the air
force i have yet to talk about it
and
is that by choice
it was it was so such a serious moment
in my life yeah that i have yet to
really find
funny aspects of it that i could bring
it to the stage i've gone to therapy and
all that other stuff but it's just
it's hard to like really put yourself
out there because it's such a real
moment and if they don't react the way
you want them to how am i going to react
yeah that's a good point is there
is there like a fear
behind that or
in terms of yeah it's talking about that
or just because i'm if i'm gonna fully
give myself to the audience and they
don't receive it
what will it do to me mentally
that
will that just
uh
reinforce what i already feel
will i feel better will it take a weight
off my shoulders i haven't even tried it
yet yeah
for sure
yeah i i think that's an interesting
thing because there's a lot of people
that don't talk about
that don't get that personal right like
yeah probably a thing that most people
have that are just like yo
i've got this thing but i'm not gonna
just go dive into it i i remember um
maybe it was a ali sadiq
who i freaking loved just saw him a
couple weeks ago
doesn't talk about really like
his time in jail and i think part of it
is like
there's a separation of you know i don't
want to
put that out there i think the way
from what i understand is like he
doesn't want you to associate him with
that part of his life like because it
happened a long time ago this is who he
is now and i just but
in his storytelling
he brings those things and those moments
up like i mean the puss and boots joke
off of comedy central i said put some
boots plus uh mexican and boots
uh often central with such a visual
uh
he's thinking about his last pornhub
search as well yeah
yeah that's on me i i i'll put that one
out to netflix with such a visual story
of like that environment but it was so
funny but he's so funny just telling
stories in general i always find it
interesting that even like people who
have been through stuff or you know that
they've got a certain background
but they talk about everything else but
that thing and that was his biggest
story
mm-hmm his right views and all that was
the thing
yeah yeah
yeah
awesome oh short bus pull-ups said i
learned a lot here today thanks
good
yeah well that that is the goal so
overall
would you think it was special chris
uh
for all of us
the special was great uh
i i hate i hate when when i hear
that was great for a female comedian
you know what i mean like
taylor tomlinson is a comedian a hundred
percent and she she
shows you on this stage
that she not only kills she got seven to
eight applause breaks
in an hour
uh which earthquake did not do
by the way
earthquake killed but he didn't get an
applause break
um and you could tell when
oh he did get one he did get one
but uh you could tell when when the
material is
prepared
and ready yeah
how it comes out
when you prepare yourself for sure uh
just uh the the topics that she was
touching i was like man she really went
there and i commend her for it was it
was really dope i liked it a lot
i am blown away
by her writing
like yeah the cadence
like the level of writing and the
details of which like punch lines hit
and connections were made it was just
so crafty to watch like yo just
but to your point like tough topic
make me feel good about seeing and
watching those moments i was like oh i
don't know if i want to like
feel like see the rest of it but it was
funny all the way through like when it
got to sort of
i think my favorite one of my favorite
parts is how she talked about other
people's reactions
to her
mental health things
i love that it was just like oh now
you're bringing almost a different
aspect to this outside of just your
reaction to it which i thought was super
dope like how her friends react how
ex-boyfriends react um yeah because
there's definitely
yeah yeah
there's a stigma of going to therapy
there's a even in the minority community
if you go to therapy you're considered
crazy
and so
a lot of people that need therapy hold
back and don't really get the help that
they need i'm an advocate i can tell you
right now me and i have my therapist on
speed dial
and we talk
because i need to process things that's
awesome
for sure
yeah it's super valuable and important
for sure and i think more
i've been hearing comics
talk about it more at open mics not to
this level
where she takes it from like
here's my mental history here's my
diagnosis here are my fears after
getting the diagnosis here's the reality
after the diagnosis here's
my me he she basically uses it like i'm
coming out as bipolar and a lot of ways
come out to her dad and her friends it's
like she uses she used like a good
analogy of like coming out as a way of
telling people about it
but she really
a lot of comics are like
wanting to make a single bit longer and
a way to do that is through
bringing in different points of view
talking about that topic
but on a timeline what is that topic in
the past the present and the future you
know and bringing points of view on it
that can all help add time
where she could have been like
my therapist just i figured i was
bipolar and then she was like oh yeah
you are you know she could have just
stopped it there but then she kept
adding and building upon it
just adding and building the connection
yeah with the credit cards and it's all
things that people think about it can
she cure me or is she just here to
collect my money yeah and it's all
aspects of therapy but i always tell
people if you have not
worked it out with a real therapist do
not bring the pain on stage because it's
gonna come off different and you gotta
you gotta learn how to process it with
somebody
yeah and i've tried to talk about a few
things i've talked about in therapy on
stage
but it it's missed so far and ended up
apologizing
it hasn't it hasn't translated yet but
it is yeah i i mean if you're doing
comedy i think you should be in therapy
maybe i mean it affects everyone i mean
i took off stand-up for the whole month
of february because of like mental
health i was like yo i need to like
i gotta i gotta get me in line before i
can like really get back on track with
things you know and i think it's
important for everyone to have that
self-awareness and
not having any embarrassment behind it
and you do something that's real special
draw i don't know uh
if you remember telling me this but you
say you take sundays
off as far as like social media
yeah
yeah i'm very much
balanced
what i mean
in the mornings also like when i first
wake up
like for the first like at least hour
i'm not on my phone
and i'm very mindful about
being more present with like
family
if we're like talking we're like talking
you know like my phone isn't in the room
things like that and mindful even on the
weekends of yep like this is this is
like family time
like we'll we're going to be doing
things i'm going to be i think and
that's something my therapist actually
said of
because like talking about one thing of
like spending time with family whether
it's spouse or extended family or
whatever and she's like
her her opinion or her recommendation
was like you don't have to pressure
yourself to like figure out how to spend
more time but just make more of the time
you spend making sure that time you do
spend with family
is higher quality you're more present
you're more with them
instead of thinking ways because like
you know we could always say we want to
spend more time with family or whatever
but just making that time more quality
will help enhance the overall
relationship
yeah it looks like you like therapy so
much you turned your office into it
well you look like you're literally
reporting from a bunker like there's
nothing on your walls there's one window
you could be in a cell right now this is
what i feel like
yeah yeah yeah this whole room yeah
chris looks like he's like bunkered down
in ukraine or something like you're
playing ukraine
yeah he's in a hospital waiting room i'm
safe but let's talk about this special
[Laughter]
yeah i hope i hope this uh let's talk
yeah i got to other people and help them
maybe yeah work through
getting into more personal topics or
just take more self-care you know mental
health and that's one thing i wanted
people to take away from the special was
uh be your genuine self whatever that
topic is
there is an aspect that can be funny
about it
but
bring yourself to
the stage if you uh
look at people
that that
don't have
good times on stage they're not really
genuine with themselves we don't really
know who they are
uh on the stage and so the material
doesn't really connect and i feel like
it connected here
because she was touching on such real
topics what medication are you guys on
yeah she had them all scream it out yeah
she brought the audience into it a lot
too
yeah and that was uh yeah
that was really dope
yeah i think the big key is uh it was
vulnerability on stage she was just
super vulnerable on stage and super
um
aware
that she's talking about a tough topic
but to your point she prepared for all
of the like the ins and outs and the i
mean the writing was like phenomenal to
talk about all these things and then put
punchlines at the end of the day
this discussion was funny yes
it had
great jokes like solid jokes all the way
throughout like seven eight laps per
minute is not easy to do
on a special like that's not easy to be
accomplished
i mean even
even being on stage you can feel
when you don't when you have that long
like pause that you're not getting any
laughs
and then you look back at the video
though it was only like 30 seconds
but
to get every eight seconds to laugh
that hour phenomenal
that's incredible that's crazy
oh nice yeah and dc rant set up she
started opening up about her agoraphobia
and claustrophobia
with a side scoop of panic attacks
yeah and it's all gradual i mean i think
the example i use is
me being born in a trailer was something
that
was something i was very embarrassed
about
and it kind of
eased its way into the set it kind of
started out as like me saying i'm from a
town where there were trailers and then
i had family that lived in trailers and
then
i was born in a trailer because that was
the hospital
and then like i just kind of eased into
then just saying it you know so it's
also for people wanting to talk about
more difficult topics
that
like easing into it not being like i
just need to come out and just say it
like you know play around with the idea
and just kind of poke around at it be a
little silly about it before you
actually just hit it right on the head
because it took me a few months to
actually just be like
i was born in a trailer i'm sorry
like it just it took a long time to get
there you know so
it's scary and uncomfortable but that's
that's where a lot of the best humor is
yeah and it's also the perspective
because i do jokes about being raised in
the ghetto and my mom will call me and
say you were not raised in the ghetto
and i was like well we have different
points of view
[Laughter]
[Music]
well that's a good perspective
i feel good about i feel good about that
uh review there
yeah and one thing if we were going to
continue this i never want
to to
down a comedian
for their special because
it takes time it takes work
and ultimately they're getting up there
and speaking their truth
taylor tomlinson she did it at a
phenomenal level
and
uh
the just i mean the topics that she was
talking about it it was so
uh
so personal uh you you have to do you
have to commend her for it it was it was
a great special yeah
my favorite part is simply the fact that
you felt comfortable after you watched
it you're like oh if somebody like and
as a comedian i think what i like what i
also liked about it just like it kind of
gave you hope that like you can talk
about these tough topics
like because there's not a lot of
specials out there where people are
talking about their mental health and
definitely not one where people are
talking about their mental health
talking about their mom dying talking
about all this personal stuff and i
think that's the kind of stuff that like
it gives you sort of a little bit of
license to be like it's okay to talk
about that stuff on stage i just seen
that maria banford i think uh
steve might as well watch it yeah oh i
haven't seen it yet on cordon
it's four and a half minutes
of
her talking about her dead mom
and it's hilarious
like it's just
like just hilarious and it's so good
and he's a beast too and you know
and she's a beast
right but to your point like i i love
the fact that
someone up and coming
is talking about such heavy topics
because that's usually what you expect
from like somebody who's legendary who
then also brings this different flavor
but for someone to be like you know i'm
just gonna talk about these things that
i'm going through um and to make it like
super personal is is dope yeah i mean
even like
i mean even developing the eating
disorder because she found out that her
mom died while she was eating a bagel
and i'm like god getting to the root of
it dude yeah that was
she got to like this is where i started
my emotional eating i was like oh my god
and it was funny
and i appreciate you saying that chris
because that is like comics like this
whole thing is comics helping comics you
know
and being positive and supportive and
any any
sort of review we do or whatever i want
to make sure yeah that that spirit is
always there that we're not
by any means trying to say this special
was better than that special or she so
and so could have done this better it's
like it's really like comics just liking
to uplift other comedians so yeah i i
agree with that intention of everything
we do here is to just uplift others
yeah you'll never uh get get me on here
to say that special sucked because i
mean you'll know it sucked because i
didn't show up
well next week we're watching joel byers
the trophy husband comedy special so
my kids will have uh the flu next week
speaking of uplift
dc ranch just gave us a super chat
thank you dc dc
rants
baby that that not the not to flex
uh but you guys have to listen to joel's
uh
special with
who was that that uh barry cat super
barry cats where he broke down your
special
holy smokes man
i mean he only listened to what three
minutes of it
yeah
i was crying in the background
you were crying yeah
yeah i was like oh
and then i was like proud because he
gave me some some props but it was it
was great i was just like but that as
uncomfortable as you felt i felt it too
as an audience member i was like oh this
is uncomfortable
but it was a good question
yeah it was like okay you had great
stuff here but let's talk about the set
let's talk about the lighting and it was
like the whole aspect
of the special and it made me look at
specials different earthquakes special
was great it was
indoors in in a closed
club-like atmosphere whereas hers was
more of a
a stadium
and you could tell the difference
between the laughs and the laughs
traveling it was it was great that barry
cats interview if you guys have not
heard it
go go listen to it
it's gold
yeah yeah
if you if you want to see joe cry
without him crying outside of his
wedding you got to go listen to that
[Laughter]
that was also it like that was also at
like midnight like we did we did the
interview
after he like got off work so it didn't
start till like
nine o'clock like eastern stand or west
coast time so i think the interview
started at like 11 and by the time we
got to the special it was about midnight
so it was like and i was
it was awesome i'm grateful
i had interviewed rodney perry
uh
and it was the week before
uh three weeks before i was going to
chocolate sundaes and after the
interview
he's like hey man we got some time
give me your three minutes
like on the spot wow
and so we weren't recording or anything
so i gave him the three minutes he goes
all right man good luck he didn't have
any real feedback
i was like
that [__] hurt this kid's a lost cause
yeah no he's like
you have a good joke here uh bring up
your energy all right uh let me know
when the special comes out i'm like
there
that was rough
but what isn't rough albert taylor
just hit us with a five dollar super
chat
yo my wife is gonna be so lit
[Laughter]
look honey
flower money
flower money oh andy just got uh the
five steps to funny workshop that's
awesome man
awesome
yay so happy to hear that yeah i'm super
i'm super proud of that workshop that's
that's definitely a workshop i wish i
had when i started so yeah let me know
how you like that there albert because
i'm super excited about that sorry i was
getting a link
to where if anyone else was interested
i can link to where we have other
classes and workshops just for anyone
interested in checking those resources
out but welcome aboard albert that's
exciting
whoa
and this was a good this was good we got
deep i did not expect it to go
that way but i'm glad it did
yeah i enjoyed it yeah yeah me too
awesome well thanks for um thanks for
hanging out and
breaking down another set with us there
chris you nailed it my friend
yeah let me know which one you want to
see next
oh yeah
um we can break down allie wong said if
you want
if you can if you can sit through the
whole thing
i think i think the only way you can do
it joel is you have to watch it all
three
because you can't just ease into the
third one because her style you have to
know her style and know like like it's
not a
because the third one
is kind of like taylor going into like
her mental things
ali wong gets more graphical more
detailed more like raw
in each special god so like it's it is
it's a
it's a ride like it's not a just
you can't start at the top uh floor with
the alley is she pregnant in the first
two
first two yeah
and that's the second one she's like
eight or nine months
yeah oh both of them she's she's
probably out there yeah
yeah and i think that's one thing that
uh
tom segura had said like they had seen
they had run into ali wang into like
some city and they're like she's intense
man her hustle
is intense she'll she does it all and
then goes on stage nine runs pregnant
shoots a special yep has the baby yep
six weeks later is back out there oh my
god man
and tom segura hustles for him to say
that she's out hustling him that's crazy
yeah there's a lot of people that are
out that way about ali wong
um
just about the hustle but also like
but when you see them specials
it's work
like it's work
yeah you could tell she puts that work
in
well let's do hers next then i guess and
then i'll watch all three
um
for context what do y'all think
let's do it yes
yes all right let's do it all right
allie wong it is
next week or do you want to do more time
um
so that's three that means you got to
watch three specials joe
yeah yeah
i can do that okay
all right and so but we're only breaking
down her latest one
right yeah we're only like
don wong
i just need to watch the others just for
context apparently
yeah there's a part where she says that
male
comedians sleep with groupies they're
called chuckle [__] and i'm like my
wife did not need to hear
oh blowing up our spot
i was like that
hey that is not me
we have to stop the specials
no not honey no no no no no
these women move fast not the men this
ain't the men you know
it wasn't me
oh yeah well should we do it no this is
me
next tuesday then do ali wong's new
special
let's do it chris o'connor said baby
cobra's the strongest of the three
baby solid
baby solid it's special
it's a
it's a good special
special
uh i know that she charges a grip and my
my wife was gonna go
see her and
she was charging oh yeah five dollars
exposure baby
you paying for that exposure baby
um she got three specials on netflix
she's got a movie out she's a producer
she's a writer on tv
yeah you paying for them credits
dang things you ain't gonna leave me and
ally long and no open mic anytime soon
not in a city near you
[Laughter]
oh dude i felt i didn't open my this
weekend and got introduced as an atlanta
comedy legend
and i was like no
you said legend like three times i was
like bruh i am no
but then uh
what do you feel about an introduction
like that at an open mic
i mean he's a he's an open micro who's
like a fan of the pod and like
like i mean i've done that for other
comics like when i was newer and there's
like a more experienced like comic who's
been in the scene and done things like
i've introduced people as legends and
ogs and all of this
so but to like hear it said at an open
mic
at an irish pub
with four people
it was just like an empty showroom and
then a few people sitting in the booths
on the edge
and then the comics in the back
so you're standing in the corner of the
room it's totally empty and then a few
people in booths not even facing the
stage and he's like atlanta comedy
legend joel byers
sunday night nothing else to do
it's pressure but it's funny because
everybody looks everybody's like
joel
yes
so uh
uh when i got
when i got back from
chocolate sundaes i did an open mic do
you understand that christmas chocolate
sundaes 19 times yeah did i did i say
albert taylor gave us a super chat as
well
did i say that i did say that
can i say something it'll be another 19
times
next week
uh
we need to watch yours
that's what we need
when i got back
set review
yeah when i got back uh
the guy introduced me as a guy who
shared the stage with kevin hart which
did not happen by the way
he just happened to be there
and this guy made all of la laugh so
he's going to make you laugh
and i was like oh hilarious
god so i guess i'm not trying new stuff
tonight
i will say it's always better to have
overhyped than under hype
for sure
like it's better that someone introduces
you as like just
the goat
rather than be like this guy is new so
give it up for him
like
my first open mic ever the guy goes this
this guy's hilarious i've shared this
stage with him a couple times i was like
p does not know who i am that's
fantastic
oh
the go-to intro in like the urban rooms
has always been like deaf comedy jam
bets comic view give it up for so and so
like the host just says it for every
single comedian and like most have never
been on anything there's like vh1
there's like listing tv channels hgtv
this boy been on the food network
but i i have been on the weather channel
and have been introduced as that's my
credit as the weather you may have seen
them on the weather channel they're like
what is happening
this show i did came on like 11 o'clock
once in like hotel rooms in tennessee
you may see him on youtube ads
yeah yeah yeah
he's definitely on your gifts
yeah i don't know what to do with that
yet but there's something there i'm
gonna sell them as nfts in like five
years
yeah are you guys applying to any
festivals
um i am i'm gonna start applying
uh i'm actually working on trying to get
like
in the next month trying to get like
solid tapes of like long sets
medium-sized sets and like shortcuts of
just straight up like
of me
i mean i of me killing in the sense of
like trying to get that nice confidence
of like
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
because i'm as a booker i'm starting to
understand
like
what videos
other bookers react to
yeah and like
and so i'm trying to like get better
around when i shoot and when i'm
recording
like it's book bull ready and that's
what i'm trying to do before i apply to
festivals like in a month or so
yeah i'm applying in a month to a
festival in colorado over the summer
uh but i want to have a solid tape and
the problem is that i'm on these shows
that are in the middle of the week
and so when i get there there's like
eight people in the crowd
and so i'm getting them to laugh but
it's not enough people in the room to
make it to make the joke pop like i
needed to
i just love he just blamed the audience
for his joke not being funny enough yeah
listen that was the biggest finesse yo
it's a small crowd it's not loud enough
the joke is
it's like getting the pop
they're not smart enough for the joke
that i'm writing
they're not smart enough
the joke doesn't get enough pop
in front of eight people
that's all you dog
at least
it was funny because i did a joke
and two people were getting their checks
and so
it cut
a half of the crowd out
it was rough no that check drop is no
joke but i had to give you i had to give
you a little
but it was the audience's fault yeah
they're not laughing louder
yeah it's their fault not mine i write
well
dude you were on chocolate sundaes
hey i don't know if you know this sure
chocolate sundae
i don't know if you know this yeah
but i'm going back
[Laughter]
oh yeah but that's the key gives you
credit when you see it
yep
you take credit
nice
all right next week we'll do alleyway
we'll do allie wong next week i'm with
it
all right cool beans joke feedback joel
yeah let's see if we got any jokes in
here uh chris we appreciate you my
friend
we'll see you next week
allie wong special
chris grulom where can people make sure
not to uh mention chocolate sundaes next
week
hilarious
that'll be the last per minute we count
with chris except it's not laughs per
minute it's chocolate sundaes per
sentence chocolate sundaes
it'll look like this
seven laughs per minute
dude these would be interesting
like
blogs or something breaking down the set
you know
yeah we'll just put that on the to-do
list yeah that'll be easy you just make
a blog
if
if you look at what happened last week
it was
it just like caught fire
and
uh i was getting tagged
by
nate jackson
uh
who then
tagged earthquake and then earthquake
tagged
the the pod it was dope
yeah
earthquake
it's just
i couldn't believe it it's
that special is just
it's just
it's ruined comedy specials for me
i think that's where the bar is i mean
it's like
yeah it's it's a very high bar we're
here to uplift everyone of course and
not say one special is better than the
other at all but like that earthquake
hits different
that's what i said it's like usain bolt
when you see us saying bolt in the race
you know you're coming in second
uh
just how far behind are you we're gonna
have to grade these on an earthquake
scale it's like one out of five
earthquakes or like
the richter scale yeah eleven laps a
minute man that's
that's no joke
like
lot like belly
gurgling laughs yes yeah
yeah and and the crazy part was this is
earthquake normally
like it wasn't like
anything
he hasn't done before
everyone in the comments was like oh
yeah we've been known this
like
yeah he's been doing this
those words exactly though we've been
known this
yep
girl
you better recognize it
i'll leave you guys to it uh we'll meet
next week and talk ali wong my guy
thanks chris
all right man see you guys next week